so what a deep learning have to do the
brain at the risk of giving away the
punchline I would say not a whole lot
but let's take a quick look at why
people keep making the analogy between
deep learning and the human brain when
you implement a neural network this is
what you do for prop and back prop and I
think because it's been difficult to
convey intuitions about what these
equations are doing really great and
descends on a very complex function the
analogy that is like the brain has
become really an oversimplified
explanation for what this is doing but
the simplicity of this makes it you know
kind of seductive for people to just say
it publicly as well as the media to
report it and certainly called the
popular imagination and there is a very
loose analogy between let's say a
logistic regression unit with a sigmoid
activation function and here's a cartoon
of a single neuron in the brain in this
picture of a biological neuron on this
neuron which is a cell in your brain
receives electric signals from you know
other neurons mu X 1 X 2 X 3 or maybe
from other neurons a 1 a 2 a 3 there's a
simple thresholded computation and then
if this neuron fires it sends a pulse of
electricity down the axon down this long
wire I have two other neurons so there
is a very simplistic analogy between a
single logistic unit between a single
neuron and your network and a biological
neuron like that shown on a right but I
think that today even neuroscientists
have almost no idea what even a single
neuron is doing a single neuron appears
to be much more complex than we are able
to characterize with neuroscience and
while some of what is doing is a little
bit like logistic regression there's
still a lot about what even a single
neuron does that no one then no human
today understands for example exactly
how neurons in the human brain learn
this is still a very mysterious process
and it's completely unclear today
whether the human brain uses an
algorithm does anything like back
propagation or gradient descent or if
there's some fundamentally different
learning principle that the human brain
uses so when I think of deep learning I
think of it as being very good and
learning very sectional functions very
complex functions to learn X to Y
mappings to learn input-output mappings
in supervised learning and whereas D is
like the brain analogy maybe that was
useful once I think the field has moved
to the point where that analogy is
breaking down and I tend not to use that
analogy much anymore so that's it for
neural networks and the brain um I do
think that the good field of computer
vision has taken a bit more inspiration
from human brains and other disciplines
that also apply deep learning but I
personally use the analogy you know to
the human brain less than I used to
so that's it for this video you now know
how to implement for prop and back prop
in gradient descent even for deep neural
networks best of luck with the pro
exercise and I look forward to sharing
more of these ideas of you in the second
course